hey is this the new Twitter yo hell yeah
dude we call it threads glad we finally
have an alternative to that Health site
owned by a Mania threads is owned by a
normal dude like totally normal okay all
right I I guess I'll just dip my toes in
the water here great joke dude that is a
sick joke man Twitter sucks right yeah
yeah
sure sure did
hey do you want to share some dank memes
okay this place sucks I don't know why I
thought it would be better what are you
gonna do about it huh what are you just
gonna stop posting you have no good
options right now and you have no life
so cut the crap and pick a size I'll ask
you again would you like to share some
dank memes